votre vidéo vous est présenté par
victoria tirer talents.com vous avez
plus de 5000 follower sur vos réseaux
sociaux
venez nous rejoindre et devenez
influenceurs grâce à victoria tirer
talents.com impossible de me faire ça je
sais pas dire c'est beaucoup trop précis
[Musique]
quel droit
ok
[Musique]
de quoi ne pas ressembler à faire rire
ses nains partout
[Rires]
moi je trouve ça moins crédible et plus
drôle mais maintenant aussi simple
[Rires]
[Musique]
m
elle va ma [ __ ] à fort boyard entendant
ça on est pas beau la même si là on
n'est pas mal a jamais prouvé en prêt à
retourner au moins ma porte pas dans la
rue voilà
[Musique]
j'attends les champions des questions
pour un champion avec ma nana avec une
candidate de japper que j'ai vécu et oui
j'avais la boule noire comme lexus un
vote sanction il a tout le temps des
marais matin ça car non ce fait paris
démarre une carrière mais jamais planté
vous n'avez jamais vu commenté louis
ward était ok pour m'essayer au quai par
plus jeunes et maquillage on imagine
canada
ça me manque ah bah tiens la barre
[Musique]
oui c'est ma tâche est maintenant dans
ces 10 38
[Musique]
non durables
pb
[Musique]
et
mais
[Musique]